visite guidée ce matin à la cité des
sciences et des techniques de la ville
est dont une partie où verra ses portes
au public le 14 mars prochain et l'autre
partie à l'automne 86 lorsque cette cité
sera terminée elle constituera à
l'ensemble unique au monde qui viendra à
compléter au plan parisien les richesses
du conservatoire national des arts et
métiers et celle du palais de la
découverte auront molinero il était une
fois un musée de la connaissance coincé
entre l'arc de triomphe et le bisc une
maison ouverte à tous où on apprenait
sans subvention ou presque à apprendre
un palais de la découverte où tous les
muséologues du monde continuent
d'ailleurs de venir pour dénicher son
secret regardez ne suffit pas il faut
comprendre
il est vrai que l'on en sort un peu plus
lourd de connaissances le monde y est
divisé en discipline physique ou
biologie et l'on peut y faire des
expériences
alors qu'une différence avec cette
nouvelle cité des sciences et de
l'industrie
et surtout pourquoi ces sept niveaux sur
3 ha qui ont déjà coûté plus de 4
milliards de francs
et si loin la villette sur le lieu même
des anciens abattoirs
en ce qui concerne le palais de la
découverte nous avons déjà commencé à
collaborer avec lui il faut bien savoir
que le public qui va dans ce genre
d'endroit n'est pas un public constant
que chaque nouvel équipement attire un
public nouveau qui bénéficie aux autres
n'oublions pas par exemple que le musée
d'art moderne de la ville de paris a vu
son public augmenter énormément après
l'inauguration du centre pompidou
donc vous pensez faire une fertilisation
croisée avec la balle elle a découvert
tout à fait avec une approche assez
différente mais complémentaire
vous pensez qu'ils auront des crédits à
la hauteur des autres
je ne sais pas social à quelle hauteur
on peut parler mais ça c'est un problème
qui concerne le palais de la découverte
et son ministère de tutelle
je pense que le contenu a été fait avec
naturellement beaucoup de scientifiques
et aussi beaucoup d'industries au total
entre 2500 et 3000 personnes auront
travaillé à réaliser le contenu
d'exposition permanente choisis sur
quels critères
c'est moi qui ai choisi un musée c'est
d'abord l'oeuvre d'un homme un homme qui
a choisi mars 86 pour ouvrir la moitié
de l'exposition permanente plus une
médiathèque 250 billets volume pour
commencer et 1 pen et harrier fans une
version septembre avec une présentation
par thème et non plus par discipline de
la terre à l'univers par exemple l'
aventure de l'aide les espaces marie
curie des valides particules en pagaille
pour l'instant un festival de béton et
de gravats très beau la lumière entre
rafle hausse est prévue et l'ont tour à
la cité comme une promesse de vie mais
suffit-il de s'appeler hall diderot pour
refaire en dur l'encyclopédie du 21e
siècle